what I am doing and what I do on a
professional basis every day is I take
the mean culture world the mean world
prequel meme Star Wars memes I mean some
of the best memes out there are Star
Wars memes and you apply that to
politics and you are able to get an
intersectional point where you can get a
young kid or some young person who might
know Star Wars but doesn't quite
understand what's going on with
impeachment and you can frame it the
world for them based on Star Wars and
actually bring them into the political
process which is very important I'm Dave
Rubin and according to the Wikipedia
editors this is the Rubin report as
always guys make sure that you're
subscribed to our channel by clicking
subscribe over there and clicking that
notification bell and more importantly
joining me today is the chief creative
officer for Turning Point USA and meme
maker extraordinaire
Manny Johnson fantastic it feels very
clever do man I know how is this taking
so long to happen you're a busy guy
you're a busy guy you're a busy guy
going around the world Jordan Peterson
it's like you know like a cut as IQ and
a half got me yeah you're half of
Peterson's brain that's a very
room-temperature IQ room temperature I
can use room temperature well I have
wanted you on for a while I'm glad we're
finally doing this and before you know
normally when I started interview I kind
of asked people their background a
little framing of the interview but I
thought first what we're gonna do is
we're just gonna throw to this video
that you just put up on Instagram this
is you going to this is outside of the
impeachment hearings yes outside of the
impeachment hearings you're asking
questions about politics and Trump and
impeachment all through the lens of a
little movie called Star Wars here we go
hey everyone Betty Johnson here at the
United States Capitol where the
impeachment trial of President Trump is
ongoing the Capitol has tens of leftist
protestors gathered at it calling for
the impeachment of President Trump
specifically we're asking them if Star
Wars references about President Trump
are worthy of having him be impeached
Senate we're going to see if these
leftist protesters believe that the
president should be impeached for
instance of killing a fictional general
General Grievous hello that I can't wait
to hear what they have to say let's go
find out many people felt a disturbance
in the force when General Grievous was
killed what do you think about the
killing of General Grievous and why you
know was it right or wrong okay uh
nobody's saying that he was a good
person
but there are a lot of big bad people in
the world and we have lost everything
what we'll do with our military should
be according to law with new x-wing
technology though there's no there's no
telling what we could accomplish I mean
you can get anyone anywhere yes yes
absolutely
[Music]
do you think that it was right or not
right to kill General Grievous is
clearly an assassination people are
saying that a thermal detonator was used
for the assassination and these are very
dangerous weapons do you have anything
to say on that you seem to care a lot
about this this is just like the kind of
music that was being saying in moss
eisely cantina
it's beautiful and General Grievous was
killed by the administration by Trump
they were saying that was illegal do you
do you believe in those kind of killings
or do you not we have a rule of law if
that rule of law says if I think you're
a bad guy then I should be able to kill
you right
that's not our rule of law I killed them
I killed them all
our rule of laws if I think you're a bad
guy I'm supposed to take you to trial
and prove that you are a bad guy that is
our rule of law in the United States of
America you can't
you must stand trial apparently he was
killed with a thermal detonator this is
like a lot of concerning to a lot of
people No
and the rule of law either we have it
and we need to live by it both the
citizens and our government or we don't
and we don't give a crap one way or the
other my lord
all right so that's just a small portion
of this video that you put out there and
I think now my audience understands why
I wanted to throw that before we do
anything else here now that one
gentleman at the end did make a good
point should we not have taken General
Grievous in and put him on trial I mean
he was the leader of the separatists no
he had just taken over from dude Count
Dooku who's a horrible human being it's
a good point yeah I mean it's true I die
who knows I mean if it was the Obama
administration definitely would have
taken him out with a drone would've
never seen it happening you know it
could have even been an American citizen
would have been boom General Grievous
gone wouldn't you do these videos
because I know most people watch them
are going oh come on he must have had to
go to a thousand different people to get
the five first five guys four or five
people
not a single I kept asking about General
Grievous and I you can see in the video
I keep like pushing them like people
felt into service in the force it's it's
very much a dark side to have this
technology with a thermal detonator and
x-wing technology to kill this general
no one nothing I even say later in the
video that Trump should just execute an
order 66 and dissolve the Senate and
then you can just get rid of this
impeachment Fiasco what does this tell
you know about these people before we
get to the Star Wars element of it and
why Star Wars memes really do marek what
does it tell you about a lot of the
activists that are out there and people
that are you know purporting to know
everything about politics I'm not even
talk about these five people
specifically them but these people that
are just out there protesting all the
time and then whenever you see them
challenge you know Crowder is really
good at this but just suddenly no no
nothing
yeah so the purpose of a video like this
is never to actually make fun of anyone
what I'm trying to do is to show that
there is a bankruptcy when it comes to
the understanding of why we are
impeaching this president why do are
these people actually out there
protesting
person in the video is protesting for
Trump's impeachment yet even when asked
if they should impeach Trump for killing
General Grievous which was my question
should we impeach Trump for killing a
fictional Star Wars villain yeah they
said yeah and so what I am doing
and what I do on a professional basis
every day is I take the meme culture
world the meme world prequel meme Star
Wars memes I mean some of the best memes
out there are Star Wars memes and you
apply that to politics and you are able
to get an intersectional point where you
can get a young kid or some young person
who might know Star Wars but doesn't
quite understand what's going on with
impeachment and you can frame it the
world for them based on Star Wars and
actually bring them into the political
process which is very important so what
is it about Star Wars because I mean the
hell out of Star Wars probably only
second to you right and there's
something particularly about the
prequels that the memes just you know
how does democracy die with under its
applause and I am the Senate and all of
those lines they seemed so powerful
right now and it's like what what do you
think it is about Star Wars specifically
that leads to this where other movies
you can mean some things from other
movies but not like the endless amount
from Star Wars that just feels right for
the moment all the time Star Wars was if
you go if you rewind the clock back to
George Lucas he based the Empire on
Nazis and he based the rebellion on
fighting Nazis and so for people like us
particularly you were able to find these
moral threads that you can pull out of
the basic Star Wars story the evil of
oppressive overarching brutalist
government how it tries to squash hope
how hope must rise in order to fight
that greatest evil which is an
oppressive overarching massive usually
by emergency powers government that can
take over all of our lives and that is
the truth that this was based on and I
think it hits at at human truth truth
that goes all the way back to our
founding and much of the Renaissance
good that comes from the idea that man
is man and man wants freedom
and man has liberties that should not be
corrupted and oppressed by a government
well it's funny because even though
you're doing it in a funny way there we
could talk about the idea that should
the Jedi have captured Grievous he was
the leader of the separatist army right
so he was an insurgent but should they
have been allowed to just kill him as
obi-wan did or should they have captured
him and taken River trial that actually
is an interesting philosophical point
that you made all the time because
that's to your point that when we killed
Soleimani everyone was saying well you
can't just kill the guy you have to
bring him in for a trial or the rest of
it that I mean that really all does add
up to why memes work yes correct
memes are a piece of non corporate non
establishment media imagery that
reflects a moment in culture and
reflects something that we're all going
through and explains it in a very simple
and shareable way if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell